-We're back
with Justin Timberlake.
Justin, I want to talk to you
about "Palmer."
It's streaming on Apple TV+.
-I like your resting face
when we come back
from commercial.
Will you do it again?
There, that's it.
That's it.
Yeah -- No.
No, a little more subtle.
A little more --
-Like that?
-Oh.
-Like, "Hey?"
-Yeah. No.
-Like I mean business?
-No, no, no, a little --
No, no, slightly more jovial.
You're Jimmy Fallon.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Try it again. Go.
That's it.
-Okay.
Think we got it?
Do I got to get a still of that?
Ridiculous.
Buddy, I always watch your
movies, and I go --
it's always so fun
to see you jump into a role.
I think you're a great actor.
And "Palmer," it's, uh --
you play --
your character's Eddie Palmer,
who is a high school
football star
who has -- his life takes
an unfortunate turn, and --
But, dude,
you nailed this character.
Can you talk about the character
and set up the movie
for everyone?
-Yeah, sure. So, I --
Thank you, by the way, man.
I appreciate it.
I play Eddie Palmer, who --
when the movie begins,
I'm coming back from
a 12-year stint in prison.
And as the movie progresses,
you kind of, find out more
about how I ended up there.
But come back to a small town
in Louisiana,
and, you know, just a guy trying
to get his life back together,
searching for some sort of
redemption,
and ends up in a situation
where a young boy
who, you know,
has a single mother
with a substance abuse problem,
ends up abandoning him
and kind of ends up in this guy,
you know.
-In his life.
-This guy ends up having to
take care of him.
-The kid is fantastic,
by the way.
-Yeah, he's --
in his first film.
-I was gonna say,
where is he from?
-Yeah, his name is Ryder Allen,
and it's his first film,
and he just -- he blew us away.
-Yeah.
We -- We auditioned
a ton of kids,
and so many of them
were amazing,
but he just kind of, like --
he showed up
and was just kind of like...
You know, like,
he had this, like,
unabashed, you know --
-Yeah.
-It was like he was
like a soda can opened up.
It was just like "Boom!"
And we just knew we had
something special with him.
And great
with improvisation, too.
-Yeah, and was he cool
with you being, like,
kind of not you?
I mean, because meeting
Justin Timberlake, you're like,
"Oh, my God, fun,"
but then you're like,
"But I have to be mean."
-Well, this is [Laughs]
This is interesting.
He actually didn't know
much about me.
I mean, like you said,
I'm 40 now.
-Yeah, he's --
-But he --
[ Chuckling ]
But he told me his mom did.
-There you go.
-So that joke played well
throughout the whole shoot.
I was like,
"Ask your mom about me."
No. No, no, no. I'm kidding.
But it was actually great,
because we developed
a real bond.
And I have become friends
with his family.
-You see it growing
through the movie.
You go, "Oh, my gosh,"
and then you go --
By the end, you go, "Dude,"
it's a -- Whew!
-Yeah, it's an emotional --
it's an emotional ride.
And really touches
on some great themes, you know?
And it's timely.
You know, it's a timely movie,
I think.
-What do you want people
to take away from this film?
-Gosh, man.
I mean, like I said,
it is about redemption.
Self love. Acceptance.
I think the theme of
acceptance -- you know,
'cause you meet this young boy,
and he likes what he likes.
-Yep.
-And it's not, you know,
stereotypical to what
the other kids around him like.
And, you know,
to watch these two
kind of people from totally
different, you know, backgrounds
kind of come together and really
give each other meaning.
This young boy gets
a father figure.
And my character, you know,
is taught this real --
I guess what it really means
to love somebody, you know,
and, you know, accept them
for who they are, and...
-But it's very like --
it's almost like,
"Hey, open your eyes
and start seeing everybody."
It's --
-Yes, see people
for who they are.
And, yeah, open your eyes,
open your ears, open your heart.
-Yeah.
-That type of thing.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Justin Timberlake
in "Palmer."
-Excuse me. Just bought these.
My friend Emily gave me this.
Every time she gets a new doll,
I get one of her old ones.
Her dog chewed this one up,
but it's still okay.
She just has to hop a little.
See?
-You know you're a boy, right?
-Yeah.
-Boys don't play with dolls.
-Well, I'm a boy, and I do.
See you later, Palmer.
-Justin Timberlake, everybody.
"Palmer" is streaming now
on Apple TV plus.
You're the best, buddy.
Hugs to the whole fam.
-You're the best, pal.
-And that little baby.
Oh, my gosh.